intended as a commuter vehicle the
world's smallest car travels up to 40
miles per hour
technicians craft the body and molds
section by section first they spread an
epoxy resin in the customers color
choice once the resin cures they lay a
sheet of fiberglass matting and
impregnate it with resin this binds the
matting to the gel coat layer narrower
strips of matting are applied around the
perimeter certain areas are reinforced
with the more porous fiberglass matting
to absorb more resin finally a second
layer of fiberglass matting and resin is
set over the entire mold the body
sections are extracted from their molds
this is the main section
the gelcoat forms a smooth and shiny
finish on the sturdy fiberglass
underneath technicians smooth the edges
of the fiberglass technicians weld
together the cars lightweight aluminum
gas tank it holds one gallon of gas they
drill a hole through it then weld on the
filler tube and screw on the cap the car
runs on three wheels - at the front and
one driven by the engine at the back
technicians assemble the wheel hubs then
mount them onto the triangular
suspension of the axle on the rear wheel
they mount a sprocket which allows the
engine to drive a chain that rotates the
wheel they connect the shock absorber on
the rear wheel to a mount underneath the
body after installing the 1 cylinder
engine in the middle of the body
technicians bolt on the chassis they
connect the shock absorber on the rear
wheel to amount underneath the body they
install all the electrical components
such as the headlight the brake lights
the turn signals and the wiper the car
can be ordered with an electric engine
in which case they install for 12 volt
rechargeable batteries
the car has a rack and pinion steering
system the steering column is attached
to a circular gear called opinion when
the driver turns the steering wheel in
one direction the pinion moves in that
direction along the rack the rack is a
track with teeth connected by rods to
the front wheels it moves and turns the
wheel steering the car the vehicle is
mechanically complete